et on va plus loin avec avait côté
gauthier rybinski bonzom gauthier je
vous appelle françois durpaire qui est
souffrant aujourd'hui nous rejoindra
depuis son domicile dans un instant en
tout cas nous eh bien on continue
évidemment à couvrir cette actualité
ukrainienne on n'avait guère d'espoir du
coup on n'a pas vraiment été déçu là la
rencontre dans ta lien entre sergueï
lavrov et demi trop cool et bats la
première à un tel niveau entre chef de
la diplomatie russe et ukrainienne n'a
rien donné sinon de vagues déclarations
de poursuivre le dialogue écouter la
conclusion du ministre ukrainien des
affaires étrangères
je suis venu ici avec un objectif
humanitaire
il s'agissait de sortir de cette réunion
avec la décision de mettre en place un
couloir humanitaire 2 et vert mariupol
malheureusement le ministre lavrov
n'était pas en position de s'engager là
dessus mais il s'entretiendra avec les
autorités responsables sur cette piste
et la médiation entamée par la turquie
qu'on disait plein de promesses compte
tenu de la proximité d'erdogan le
président turc avec les deux
belligérants n'a donc pas permis de
rapprocher les points de vue pas plus
que le sommet des 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernements en europe convient
versailles sous présidence française
nous devrait éviter à la russie de
nouvelles sanctions écoutez emmanuel
macron en ouverture de ce sommet
l'europe elle doit se préparer
tous les scénarios et quand j'ai souvent
entendu parler d'europe puissances
d'europe indépendante elle doit se
préparer à être indépendante du gaz
russe à être indépendante pour assurer
sa propre défense à être indépendante en
terme justement d'approvisionnement de
ses marchés parce que nous redécouvrons
que notre démocratie est menacée que nos
valeurs sont menacés et qu'il nous faut
donc accepter parfois d'en payer le prix
celui qui va avec les sanctions et les
contres sanctions et être prêt aussi à
défendre ses valeurs quand elles sont
attaquer l'europe qui va sans doute se
désengager progressivement du gaz russe
à plus ou moins brève échéance tout est
question de durée justement le
bombardement hier d'une maternité à
marioupol en ukraine rendent impossible
tout rapprochement françois durpaire
oui c'est si vous voulez des lignes
rouges qui sont qui sont franchies pour
l'union européenne en matière de en
matière simplement de respect des droits
humains une grande différence entre la
russie et les pays de l'union européenne
c'est que l'image elle est aide n'est
pas contrôlé du côté du côté des pays
démocratiques et donc il y a des
opinions publiques et ses opinions
publiques et bien ils réclament en
matière de dignité des choses du côté
russe on sait qu'il y à une telle
maîtrise de l'information de la part de
vladimir poutine qu on a une sorte
d'asymétrie sur le plan du rapport à la
guerre là du côté européen les opinions
publiques elles sont bien elles sont
sous le choc de ces images que qui ont
été vus par tous depuis qu'elle peut le
sud quelques heures et elle ne
comprendraient pas et bien qu'on puisse
tout laisser faire applaudir coûté n'est
que et finalement et bien les dirigeants
de l'union européenne eh bien ils sont
ils sont saouls 7 sous ce regard de
l'ensemble de leurs opinions alors
écoutez un juge comment sergueï lavrov
pour la russie lui justifiait depuis
antalya en turquie ce bombardement
à
propos de la maternité
ce n'est pas la première fois que nous
assistons à des cris pathétique sur les
prétendus atrocités commises par les
forces armées russes
lors de la réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies
notre délégation a présenté les faits
selon lesquelles cette maternité est
occupé depuis longtemps par le bataillon
azoff et d'autres radicaux
les femmes en couche les infirmières et
tout le personnel de soutien ont été mis
à la porte c'était la base de
l'ultra-radical bataillon azoff
cynisme gauthier rybinski ou bien vrais
doutes sur les circonstances de ce
bombardement dans lequel d'après les
autorités ukrainiennes trois personnes
dont une fillette ont péri alors je vais
commencer par la deuxième partie de
votre question est ce qu'il y a un doute
d'abord je voudrais dire qu'à ceux à ce
genre d'informations même si elle était
moins grave jusqu'à présent nous n'avons
pas hésité à france 24 a donné des
informations et à émettre des doutes
c'était par exemple le cas à propos du
nombre de morts rue ce qu'on a que les
ukrainiens ont signalé au bout de 4 5
jours on faisait état de 5000 morts
russe c'était un élément de propagande
c'est clair même une propagande
vertueuse entre guillemets mais c'était
un élément fort et nous l'avons donné
nous avons donné également les
informations selon lesquelles et qui
sont vérifiées un certain nombre de
gardes frontières ukrainiens à la
frontière entre vifs et schémas en
pologne se livrer à des insultes et à
des mauvais traitements concernant les
africains donc on va continuer dans ce
sens là et vous verrez après comment on
peut équilibrer la chose le bataillon
azoff dont parle sergueï lavrov c'est un
bataillon effectivement composé de
membres de l'extrême droite
l'ukrainienne avec parfois même des
auxiliaires européen et il a été formé
en 2014 pour justement essayer de
contrôler marioupol au moment où ça se
passait mal pour l'ukraine et puis au
moment aussi où l'armée régulière et
craignait n'était pas à la hauteur donc
cette ce bataillon a été suprémacistes
blancs soyons clairs ce bataillon a été
enrôlé depuis dans les forces du
ministère de l'intérieur ukrainien
avec pour ministre quelqu'un qui
s'appelait arsène havas kof qui était
aussi quelqu'un d'extrême droite mais
qui a dû démissionner en juillet dernier
est ce que ça veut dire que ce bataillon
est toujours puissant il est capable de
faire des choses oui il serait tout à
fait capable de prendre des boucliers
humains c'est vrai maintenant on
renverse le saviez si vous voulez bien
souvenons nous que il y avait en 1943
massacre à katyn pas très loin enfin du
côté de smolensk de 22000 officiers
polonais qui représente l élite et le
futur industriel de la pologne ils ont
été assassinés par le nkvd qui était une
police intérieure politique soviétique
et la faute en a été attribuée aux nazis
alors loin de moi l'idée te disculper
les nazis de quoi que ce soit mais cette
manipulation peut avoir lieu simplement
une remarque qui me paraît être
importantes on sait que vladimir poutine
a des idées fixes et borné sur
l'histoire ce qui semble accuser à
travers les paroles de lavrov les
ukrainiens c'est précisément marioupol
ou le bataillon azoff a vu le jour mais
aujourd'hui à marioupol il n'y a
quasiment plus de gens du bataillon à
soft on est en 2014 l'histoire s'est
figé l'a en partie pour goûter dans
l'esprit potiron l'estrie coûteux merci
gauthier pour cette précision c'est
important évidemment nous continuons de
vous donner les détails puisqu'une
enquête est déclenchée vais sur ces
évènements de cette maternité c'est dans
ce contexte en tout cas qu'on assiste à
de bien curieux rapprochement des
émissaires du gouvernement américain
dépêché à caracas auprès du président
vénézuélien nicolás maduro jusque-là
ennemi juré des américains tout comme
elles iront avec laquelle washington se
dit plus près que jamais d'un accord sur
le dossier du nucléaire et l effort côté
américain françois durpaire de compenser
la rupture avec moscou
oui l'objectif des états unis on le voit
bien c'est de couper la russie du reste
du monde y compris de ses alliés les
plus proches et et vous avez raison
d'abord de l'iran et du venezuela mais
j'allais dire que les états unis là se
font un peu la main sur le venezuela et
l'iran mais dans le viseur l'hésitation
on saute tous évidemment la chine parce
qu'une grande question qui se pose à
washington c'est quelle est l'utilité
des sanctions si la chine ne fait pas
partie de ces sanctions font rappeler
que la chine est le plus grand
partenaire commercial de la russie 1 14
% des exportations de la russie 19 % de
ses importations
et il ya une chose évidemment très très
très forte c'est que si effectivement la
chine ne rentre pas dans le système de
sanctions de l'union européenne et des
états unis et bien tout pourrait être
remise en cause on sait d'ailleurs que
l'efficacité des sanctions elle est
moindre pour des états autocratique ont
parlé avec gauthier à l'instant du toit
de l'opinion publique et de la manière
dont on parle des images mais les
sanctions c'est pareil les sanctions
elles ont moins de poids sur un régime
autocratique avec une société gouvernée
par une dictature qu'elle soit un
dictateur sauf que ce soit un indicateur
plus plus assumer et donc il est
nécessaire d'avoir un régime de
sanctions qui soit unifiée concertée et
pour le moment évidemment venezuela iran
et et demain c'est la chine qui est le
sujet de préoccupation à washington
comment vous fait pour que la chine est
bien décédé véritablement de de paix et
de dire là ça va trop loin on ne peut
pas aller vers vers une guerre qui
remettrait en cause par exemple des
marchés très important pour les chinois
le marché notamment européens
la russie elle peut néanmoins gauthier
rybinski faire capoter ces
rapprochements réelle ou supposée entre
entre washington caracas téhéran alors
c'est ce que vient de dire françois dû
repérer et capital à mon sens c'est le
poids dans cette affaire c'est le grand
retour de l'idéologie cette guerre c'est
là où on avait cru que la matérialité
des choses pouvaient permettre des
arrangements avec vladimir poutine et
rationnel on se rend compte que il y as
est un grand retour du politique et de
l'idéologie et comme le disait françois
à l'instant et bien les sanctions ça n'a
pas tout à fait le même effet selon
qu'on est qu'on s'adresse à une société
de type démocratique ou autoritaires
autoritaristes et là dans le cas que
vous citiez dans l'iran le cadre de
l'iran et le cadre du venezuela il ya
probablement quelque chose qui relève
aussi à leurs moindres pour l'iran mais
pour le venezuela ce réflexe pavlovien
anti américain veut qu'on considère
encore aujourd'hui la russie comme un
état ami alors que s'il ya bien un état
dans cette partie du monde est ultra
capitaliste est plutôt pratique c'est
bien la russie mais les clichés
idéologiques ont la vie dure merci
gauthier rybinski et merci à françois
durpaire oui vous voulez a ajouté
françois oui d'ailleurs d'un mot le 18
là on est bien l'exemple puisqu'il ya un
régime de sanctions très fort contre le
venezuela et pourtant le venezuela n'a
pas les armes économiques de la russie
on a vu toutes les limites du régime de
sanctions contrôle des 18 et là mais qui
tient bien qui tient bon en tout cas ce
régime de 2,2 maduro merci françois
durpaire à vous aussi je rappelle que
vous étiez souffrent et que vous n'avez
donc pas pu vous rendre ici même en
plateau mais vous avez tenu malgré tout
à participer à l'émission et nous vous
en sommes extrêmement reconnaissants
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour citer le
livre de le titre pardon de la bande
dessinée qui sort aujourd'hui après la
présidente et totalitaire vous publiez
avec farid boudjellal cette bd elysées
avec un z comme zemmour votre regard
françois sur la campagne d'eric zemmour
en deux mots
exactement c'est tout c'est une bd
d'anticipation politique et il s'agit de
non seulement de parler de la campagne
électorale mais des effets politiques à
long terme de l'arrivée d'eric zemmour
dans le paysage politique et notamment à
la droite de l'échiquier politique
français et notamment les rapports aussi
entre la france et l'afrique c'est un
des éléments de cette bd donc c'est
distrayant mais c'est aussi évidemment
pour informer et faire réfléchir merci
encore justement et le dire c'est
peut-être la prochaine discussion
zemmour proconsul de poutine en france
voilà peut être une idée pour la
prochaine bande dessinée va peut-être en
train d'en débattre je n'incite pas noté
spectateurs hier mais il se trouve qu'il
est bon en ce moment même où qui
s'apprêtent à le faire avec valérie
pécresse de l air merci beaucoup
gauthier merci également à vous françois